in the winter of 1911 1912 the political
earthquake in Asia brought one of our
last links to the ancient world crashing
down Imperial China had outlasted the
Western Roman Empire the Byzantine
Empire the Holy Roman Empire for 2,000
years it had withstood civil wars and
foreign invasion only to dramatically
implode after less than six months of
unrest the emperor on the throne at this
turning point in history a six-year-old
boy named Puyi born into an ossified
court and brought up an unimaginable
luxury the boy Emperor spent the first
six years of his life as a living God
before finding himself turned into a
political force all a relic of a dead
age but there was more to Puyi than just
one frightened child an entitled brat
who grew up to be a spoiled playboy
before ending his life a convicted war
criminal who he was the living
embodiment of China's crazed 20th
century transformation join us today as
we journey through the life of China's
Last Emperor
on the 7th of February 1906 the boy who
would one day rule China opened his eyes
for the very first time at the moment of
his birth Bowie was perhaps the single
most privileged child on the face of the
planet
his father Princeton was a member of the
Ching dynasty a group of ethnic Manchu
who'd ruled China since 1640 for his
uncle Gwangju was the current Emperor
yet the apparent stability of phu Yi's
young life masked a much deeper series
of problems by 1906 the
two-thousand-year-old Chinese Empire was
not really built on rock but rather on
shifting sands and this slippery
treacherous sands it has a name it
called itself 6e the Dowager Empress of
China born in 1835 6e had once been a
low-ranking concubine of the Shang Fang
Emperor however should also been the
only person to bear the Emperor the son
so Wang Zhang Feng died in 1861 6e had
suddenly gone from absolute nobody to
mother of the new emperor mother mother
of the Emperor was a job with many perks
while Cixi's Emperor sung Hongzhi was
still a child all the ruling was done on
his behalf by an eight-member regent
council from the counsels perspective 6e
was a nuisance a concubine who'd simply
gotten lucky
but while six he certainly had gotten
lucky with her pregnancy she was also
someone who made her own luck in
November of 1860 1/60 orchestrated a
palace coup kicking out the council and
installing yourself and two loyalists as
Regents in their place it was an
arrangement that effectively handed 6e
the keys to China so long as their
Emperor son were a minor she could rule
on his behalf and once he was no longer
a minor well there are always other
children right On January the 12th 1875
Tongzhi died at the age of 19 in
circumstances so suspicious he might as
well have literally been suffocated by
Cixi's ambition barely was the emperor's
body colder than 60 announced she
adopted her five-year-old nephew and
made in the new Guangxu Emperor now
normally just declaring her adopted
nephew emperor of China would go about
as well as well URI declaring our
adopted nephew emperor of China but in
1875 Dixie had built such a power base
that
nobody could stand in our way and so
came the second period of Chinese
history where a little boy play acted at
being Emperor while succeeded all the
ruling this time round those six he
allowed the Emperor to reach maturity
presumably on the assumption that he'd
do just about whatever she said but six
he had badly judged gwangsu
in 1898 the Emperor suddenly did
something that shocked her to her very
core he grew a backbone and tried to
reform Imperial China this is actually a
very astute move by 1898 the Ching
dynasty had lost to opium wars barely
survived the Taiping rebellion been
humiliated in the first sino-japanese
war and had almost lost their mandate as
man choose to be ruling over the ethnic
Han Chinese the only way to stop a
revolution from exploding was to
introduce something like a European
system but that would involve both
gwangsu
and sixty giving up power and asking
sick C to give up power was like asking
Napoleon's who go easy on all the
conquering lope on September the 22nd
1898 a military force loyal to 6e
converged on the Forbidden City
kwang-soo was imprisoned in his palace
his reforms were scrapped and his
supporters they were driven into exile
in his place sixty assumed full control
of China and that's where things stood
when puyi was born in 1906 with the
Emperor a prisoner sexy on the throne
and the public post of rioting over
Guang zhuzh blocked reforms little did
the newborn child know it but soon all
of those factors would combine to
destroy his entire world
[Music]
it was a chilly mid-november day when
Dowager Empress sixy breathed her last
in one of the vast and gloomy rooms of
the Imperial Palace her penultimate act
was to inform the world that the Gwangju
Emperor had died the day before almost
certainly poisoned on Cixi's orders then
with our last breath already rattling in
her throat she named her successor as
little poo u6 he passed away on the 15th
of November 1908 barely two weeks later
two year old Puyi was coronated in the
heart of the Forbidden City it is said
that when baby poo you first saw the
scale of the palace heard the drums and
saw the thousands of eunuchs there to
witness the coronation he bawled his
eyes out for the toddler that ceremony
marked the moment he forever lost any
chance of a normal childhood as the new
Emperor Puyi was now followed everywhere
by armies of eunuchs attending to his
every whim
to give just one slightly gross example
every time he did a poop he would be
watched by dozens of grown men who had
then regally passes bedpan to the head
eunuch for examination still there were
upsides to being a living God especially
if you were a tiny sadist maybe you know
that old Twilight Zone episode where
everyone is super scared to the little
boy you can read minds and turn people
into jack-in-the-boxes well that was
basically who used Charlton at a young
age the boy Emperor discovered everyone
had to do whatever he told them and
young PE he loved nothing more than
ordering his servants to beat random
eunuchs into a wailing and bloody pulp
what the puyi would hold this power for
long though on October the 9th 1911 an
explosion leveled a small house in the
central city of all Chiang now part of
Wuhan when police investigated the blast
they found in the rubble a list of names
linked to a nationalist revolutionary
movement at the time China was suffering
a constant low-level threat from such
movements not that they ever went
anywhere though which may be why the
police seemed so blase about the list I
mean what were these dumb
revolutionaries really gonna do capture
the whole look well wait wait hang on
that's actually exactly what they did by
December the uprising and Wu Chang had
inspired 14 provinces to go into
rebellion the provisional government had
been established in Nanjing and a heart
Revolutionary Sun yat-sen
seeing their brain on the verge of
collapse Prince Cheung called the great
general Wan XI Chi out of retirement to
save the Ching dynasty
late that month one finally asked
representatives of the rebel governments
what they actually wanted their answer
the end of the Ching dynasty to which
they probably replied well that's it and
they replied well yes that's it
it profile after that well in that case
we'd like to imagine once a guy giving a
sly little smile here allow me to help
when the end of Imperial China came it
was with embarrassing swiftness in
January the rebels declared a republic
centered around Nanjing on the 26th of
that month Hwan went to the palace and
told the imperial family he was prepared
for war but that in his estimation they
would all end up as dead as a Norwegian
Paris a versed some of the family they
held out but one was persuasive working
behind the scenes he offered the King a
simple choice either accept a massive
bribe now to end their dynasty or be
beheaded when the rebels finally took
Beijing everybody took the bribe On
February the 12th 1912 six-year-old Puyi
he was forced to abdicate the rebels had
already agreed that he could continue to
live in the Forbidden City even keep his
servants and be given enough money to
live like an emperor for the rest of his
life given all this it's highly unlikely
the boy even noticed that anything had
changed he probably didn't even notice
that his palace had now become a prison
that March new constitution was
promulgated once help in ending the
Ching dynasty was rewarded by the rebels
who made him presidents and just like
that 2,000 years of Imperial Chinese
rule came to an abrupt end well almost
Babu Yi may be known to history as the
Last Emperor there was actually another
Emperor who started his reign after pre
he abdicated
you already know him as Arantxa Kai and
his imperial ambitions were about to
ensure China's 20th century would be a
nightmare the problems started when the
Chinese Republic held its first
elections in January of 1913 as you
might expect they returned the majority
for the rebels the president won decided
he no longer needed these guys now the
Ching dynasty were gone and had the head
of the National Assembly murdered this
resulted in the rebels taking up arms
again only for ones that really go to
war this time he might have told the
Ching in January 1912 there a war could
only end in defeat but when it was his
own power on the line he clearly felt
differently by March 1913 hit one now
had only one in a loose sense in many
provinces power was concentrated in the
hands of military leaders who only paid
lip service to Beijing but still one had
no immediate challenges to his rule come
the ends of 1915 he was even feeling
secure enough to have himself declared
the new Hong Jang Emperor this turned
out to be a mistake
c11 the 1913 war because of the backing
of the military but even the military
wasn't willing to kowtow to an
illegitimate emperor 83 days after
announcing his new empire Wilde was
forced at gunpoint you dissolve it
barely three months after thats on june
the sikh 1916 President Wong died by
some measures the true last emperor of
China but only by some measures after
one died China disintegrated into
multiple warring States ruled by former
military generals in the second year
what became known to history as the
warlord era a ching loyalist named Zhang
Zhang marched on Beijing and restored PU
to the throne by now a boy of 11 pre
ruled during his second reign for a mere
11 days before the Warlord's Duan Chi
recaptured Beijing sent Shang Tsung into
exile and forced for you to abdicate all
over again this time PO he really would
be the last emperor
[Music]
in early 1919 a man named Reginald
Johnson arrived outside the Forbidden
City by now China was three years deep
into the warlord era and the countryside
was a wasteland but Beijing was eerily
calm
ever since Duan chiri had captured the
city and forced Puyi to abdicate for the
second time no new warlords had tried to
retake the capital it was during this
lull that guan's government had
telephoned the British Foreign Office
with an extraordinary request they
wanted an English language tutor when
asked why they replied they wanted
lessons for their deposed Emperor and
now here Reginald Johnson was on an
official mission to teach PG English
Johnson's first meeting with his new
people involved being led into a room
deep in the Forbidden City and
countering three times to a thirteen
year old
despite this Johnson would play to
rights that he felt instant affection
for the teenage Pooh you
however it's doubtful this affection
would have survived much contact with
reality unbeknownst to the teacher puyi
was now a fully fledged sadist who made
flogging at random servant's part of his
daily routine over the following months
Johnson and PU they held daily classes
the more Thomason got to know PE the
more he began to realize how much the
boy who had everything really had
nothing
he discovered Pooh you needed glasses
and that it's so far been refused
because Emperor's weren't expected to
wear them he also discovered the pre
news life was a gilded cage and that
even in this cage servants were stealing
from him being a practical man Johnson
tried to help his people he got the boy
glasses arranged him to spend some time
outside the palace and other things like
that after a while you might even say
that the man and the boy became friends
and it was this friendship that would
save pries life outside the walls of the
Forbidden City trouble was brewing in
1920 a coalition of warlords angry that
Japan had annexed South Manchuria drove
Duan out of Beijing it was the sixth
change of regime that Hui had survived
since the 1912 revolution it was also
nearly the last in the fall of 1924 two
warlords Jiang Xiao Ling and Feng
Yuxiang forged an alliance to conquer
Beijing and new as their armies swept
into the city
Fang made a bold pronouncement he would
not be bound by the 1912 treaty to allow
Puyi to continue living in the Forbidden
City either the boy Emperor left his
imperial home or he would face the
consequences not the Buyi was really a
boy anymore now aged 80
even had a wife in extremely awkward
fashion the imperial court had given per
year stack of photos of girls in 1922
and told him to pick one to be his bride
police first tries to girl named Wang
Shu had turned out to be only 12 so
instead had married empress wang Rong
and taken the underage Wang Shu as his
consort and let's just leave that there
because we don't really want to think
too much about it as Wang's army
approached Palace Reginald Johnson
desperately tried to find a foreign
embassy that would grant pootie asylum
there was no one even Johnson's own
employees the British they refused
finally at the last moment Johnson had
his lightbulb moment why not ask the
Japanese on November the 5th 1924 puyi
Empress went wrong and the consort Wang
Shu all fled to the Japanese embassy
about four months later the Japanese
offered to move Puyi out of Beijing
we'll send you somewhere safe they said
and so it was that On February 23rd 1925
a disguised puyi boarded a train bound
for changjun a Chinese City the Japanese
had occupied after winning the first
sino-japanese war it was the start of a
relationship between the last Emperor
and Imperial Japan that would end in
horrific bloodshed
for the next few years per year lived a
life that can best be described as
dissolute in Japanese controlled Tianjin
he and Empress went wrong reinvented
themselves as a pair of rich della
taunts Bui spent money on luxuries pets
and social connections using his faded
Imperial grandeur to gain entry to the
city's whites-only clubs went wrong
meanwhile became addicted to opium
spending her life in eight listless days
it's likely the pair barely even noticed
is across the border Chiang kai-shek's
Nationalist Army finally defeated the
Warlord's and reunified China for his
part Bowie was far more concerned with
his impending divorce from Wang sheild
remedy underage consult welp she grew up
decided she could be better than some
rich sadist and laughs even though he
tried to bully her into staying so well
well done her yes it wouldn't be quite
true to say poo yeap spent his six years
in Tanjung ignoring China we know this
because in 1931 poo you wrote to the
Japanese Minister for war demanding help
in restoring his empire as luck would
have it the Japanese were in need of an
emperor on September the 18th 1931 the
Japanese Imperial Army had used the
pretext of a terrorist attack to annex
the rest of Manchuria they claimed that
they were restoring order that Manchuria
would now become the independent states
of Manchu quo a place where Chinese
Japanese Koreans Mongols and mandrews
could live in harmony in reality of
course Manchu quote would be a Japanese
puppet state in which all other races
were treated as inferior but the
Japanese they did not want the world to
notice they needed a fig leaf of
legitimacy to cover their plant
atrocities a nominal ruler who was
ethnically from Manchuria and could
claim to be Manchu cause legitimate
leader in November of 1931 the Japanese
they wrote back to poo you we can't
restore you to your old throne they told
him but well hey how about you come and
rule this new shiny state we just
created ever the entitled fool Bowie
said yes on March the 9th 1932 puyi
became presidents of manchu quelled how
would lead the last emperor appeared to
have everything he ever wanted a state
to rule people who claim to love him
only pooi knew that behind the scenes
had signed secret documents transferring
all power in Manchu quote to the
Japanese Imperial Army in March of 1934
Puli was elevated to man chuckles
Emperor
the Japanese reported the citizens of
their puppet state had rejoiced but that
seems unlikely by 1934 it was clear just
what a cruel regime was leading Manchu
quo was a racist authoritarian state the
persecuted non Japanese citizens
mercilessly in 1932 for example the
Japanese responded to an act of sabotage
by rounding up 3,000 Chinese civilians
and mass executing them all but Paul Yi
he didn't flinch at these atrocities he
simply indulged in his own as mantric
was Emperor Puyi was crueler than had
ever been in Beijing yet servants beaten
to death for the smallest imagined
infractions when he discovered when
wrong had been impregnated by a Japanese
lover he had the newborn baby
Thrun alive into the palace boiler while
most of the blame for mentor equals
cruelty can be placed at the feet of the
Japanese pooi was far from innocence and
things were about to get a lot worse on
July the 7th 1937 a skirmish between
Chinese and Japanese forces at the Marco
Polo Bridge turns into a full-blown
Japanese invasion of China the second
sino-japanese war had just begun by the
time it was over both nations
ann's manchu quo itself would lie in
ruins
of all the phony celebrations that have
been thrown by phony rulers over the
years none could have been quite so
phony
as the one that took place in Montreux
quo in October of 1943 by that point the
second sino-japanese war had become just
another front in World War two epic
punch up mantra Kuo had seen waves of
show trials and executions citizens had
been turned into medical experiments for
Japanese doctors yet that October day
Hui still presided over a celebration of
ten years of Manchu row as an
independent state it brings to mind
Robespierre
throwing his great feast in the middle
of the reign of terror as thousands of
Parisians were marched to the guillotine
but even Paul Yi couldn't have been as
blind as Robespierre to the fate that
awaited him he was the cruel powerless
emperor of a sadistic failed state there
was only one way his last regime could
end in July of 1944 the first American
planes they began bombing Manchu cual as
cities fell and sheets of flame we clung
to the belief that even if Japan was
defeated he would still be allowed to go
on ruling his ancestors homeland by the
time a year had passed though it was
clear that pre-use hopes was so much ash
on August the 9th 1945 the USSR launched
a ground invasion of Mantua the arrival
of the Red Army was like a cleansing
fire sweeping over Mantua 200,000 people
were killed in just two weeks
not the Puli was around to see it though
within a week of the first soviet tanks
entering his territory the Emperor had
been captured by the Red Army he would
turn out to be the lucky one empress
when wrong was taken alive by Chinese
partisans she would starve to death in a
jail cell just one year later for Paul
Yi this was the end trucked into a
Siberian gulag the last emperor was now
nothing but a mere war criminal although
he lied through his teeth to save his
skin at the 1946 International Military
Tribunal for the Far East the Japanese
version of the Nuremberg trials cui was
done for and he knew it
the final act came just four years later
on October the 1st 1949 Mao Zedong's
communists they succeeded in taking
control of mainland China the new
government in Beijing contacted the
Soviets asking for their war criminal
Emperor to be returned the Soviets
happily obliged
shortly after Bowie van
for good into the black hole of Mao's
internment camps there was no public
execution no gun shot in a secluded
courtyard just an emperor who stepped
off a plane and vanished after three
regimes and 45 years the tale of the
last emperor is finally at an end or was
it fast forward a decade to 1960 imagine
you're walking through communist Beijing
all around you Chinese workers in
overalls ride bikes past concrete blocks
up on the side of buildings mouths
beaming face stares down at you it's the
most typical communist scene you could
possibly imagine with one exception see
over there by the flowerpots
see that old withered gardener tending
to his plants he may look like just
another ordinary peasant but that
elderly gardener has some tales to tell
tales about revolution and war and about
growing up in a palace where everyone
had to do whatever he said tales about
the three separate times that he was
China's last emperor of course these are
only stories you only have to look at
the gardener to know that he's a nobody
an old man who dreams of being a
somebody but there's something in the
way his face sometimes looks across the
city like he's seeing a different
Beijing one that vanished decades ago
something about the way the Communist
Party sometimes calls on him to meet
visiting dignitaries parades him around
like he's something more than just a
crazy old man perhaps the strangest part
is that the old man never looks upset by
this never looks as your imagine a
faller Emperor to look in such
circumstances instead on these rare
occasions you can't help but notice how
happy he appears almost as if after a
lifetime locked in different gilded
cages the elderly gardener who calls
himself puyi is finally free so I really
hope you found that video in trouble if
you did smash that like button below
don't forget to subscribe hit the bell
all of that good stuff also check out
our new channel Geographics it's sort of
like by graphics except about places
rather than people that is linked to
below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]